Guten Tag.
Okay. Schönen guten Tag. Mein Name ist Sulel Östschelig Baran.
Ich bin hier als Assistentätik auf dieser Situation.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmengeschiff führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, guten Tag Frau Baran. So habe ich verstanden.
Ja, gerne natürlich.
Ja, super. Also wie heißen Sie den?
Mein Name ist David.
Gut.
Habt ihr nicht verstanden? Könnten Sie bitte wiederholen?
Gut, K-U-R-T.
K-U-A-T.
Ja, RT.
RT, kurz. Ja.
Das ist der Nachname, ja.
Ja, ja, verstehe.
Und David mit Theodor oder Dora?
Mit Dora.
Ja, super. Und wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 54 Jahre alt.
54.
Ja, okay.
Und wann wurden Sie geboren?
Am 23. März 1969.
Okay.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,73 m.
Und Sie wollen sicher auch das Gewicht wissen.
Ich bin circa 96 kg.
Okay, super.
Und wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt?
Mein Hausarzt? Ja, genau.
Das ist Dr. Leiple.
Leiple. Okay.
Super. Herr Kurt, würde ich sagen, was hat Sie uns geführt?
Frau Doktor, ich komme heute als Akut,
sozusagen als Akutfall zu Ihnen,
und ich habe mich auch schon seit circa 3 Stunden im Linken unterbaut.
Nach vorne.
Das ist manchmal so wellenartig.
Und ich würde sogar sagen, das sind eher so Koliken.
Ja, okay.
Die zum Teil sehr stark werden.
Ja, okay, super.
Super ist das gar nicht, Frau Doktor, das ist sehr schwer.
Ja, ich werde entschuldigen.
Danke für Ihre Information.
Und Sie sagen mir vom Brücken an,
unser Bauch gewandert, oder?
Den Bereich der linken Flanke.
Okay, linken Flanke.
Das fängt es an und das zieht den Bauch runter.
Ja, okay.
Aber ist mehr im Unterbauch eigentlich, die Schmerz?
Ja, okay, okay, verstehe ich.
Und seit 3 Stunden haben Sie gesagt,
und das ist ganz stark jetzt,
also im Moment, die sind noch auszuhalten.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie.
Und wie stark die Schmerzen auf einer Skala,
wenn eines sehr leichte und sehr stark Schmerzen sind?
Jetzt aktuell würde ich sagen, 9 bis 10.
9 bis 10, sehr stark Schmerzen.
Und könnten Sie mir diese Schmerzen genau überschreiben?
Also Sie haben mir Kollegen und Wellenartige gesagt,
noch etwas, also brennende, oder?
Also, ja, das kann ein anderes sein,
eine Möglichkeit.
Schätzen Sie ein?
Nein, aber das ist ein wirklich im Bauch.
Das geht bis in die Leiste.
Und zieht so ein bisschen runter in die Leiste.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
dass ich auf die Toilette muss zum Wasser lassen,
aber ich habe nicht viel.
Und das ist sehr anstrengend,
dann tut es noch mehr weh, also im Bauch.
Okay.
Und stellen die Schmerzen in irgendwelche Körperregionen aus?
Ja, in die Leiste, habe ich ja gesagt.
In die Leiste nur.
Okay.
Und gibt es einen Auslöser für die Schmerzen?
Nein, es ist einfach ganz plötzlich gekommen.
Ja, okay.
Das ist das erste Mal, dass ich so etwas habe,
ist es ganz schlimm.
Ja, okay.
Gibt es etwas, was die Schmerzen verstärkt oder lindert?
Nein, weiß ich nicht.
Es wird mehr, mehr, weniger, aber im Moment wird es noch stärker.
Das ist ganz schlimm.
Ja, okay.
Und wie verhalten sich die Schmerzen im Laufe der Zeit?
Gut, das sind jetzt drei Stunden her.
Das hat langsam angefangen,
aber relativ schnell ganz...
Okay, ich muss unterbrechen.
Langsam angefangen oder plötzlich?
Sie haben mir gesagt, akut.
Ja, das hat plötzlich aber mit wenig Schmerzen.
Das mache ich damit.
Im jetzt, also wie verhalten sich die Schmerzen im Laufe der Zeit?
Ja, sage ich ja.
Wie oft soll ich das wiederholen, Frau Doktor?
Jetzt ist es schlimm geworden, deswegen bin ich ja da.
Ja, verschlechtert, okay.
Deswegen bin ich zu Ihnen gekommen.
Ja, okay.
Und Herr Kurt, haben Sie Angst?
Haben Sie Angst?
Sie sprechen also sehr schnell und...
Ich bin schnell.
Haben Sie Angst?
Nein, das habe ich nicht, aber natürlich, das macht mir Angst.
Ich weiß, ich muss es...
Ja, ich verstehe Sie, aber bitte beruhigen Sie sich.
Ich würde Sie auch bitten,
das mir gegen die Schmerzen zu geben, bitte.
Also, das ist kaum aufzuhalten.
Ja, okay. Also, ich möchte...
Haben Sie Angst?
Ja, ich erkläre jetzt.
Ich möchte nicht jetzt Ihnen einen Schmerzmittel geben,
weil ein Schmerzmittel eingaben kann die Diagnose verpalschen.
Ja, also können Sie...
Ja, das ist stark geschmackt.
Nein, ich glaube nicht, dann gehe ich woanders hin.
Also, ein ganz starker Schmerzen.
Also, deswegen bin ich gekommen
und Sie wollen mir keine Schmerzsammeliten geben,
das ist ja kaum auszuhalten.
Ja, okay.
Und...
Geben Sie bitte, was gegen die Schmerzen.
Die Diagnose können Sie ja immer noch machen.
Ja, okay. Also,
wenn Sie das möchten,
können Sie Ihnen einen Schmerz geben, oder was?
Bitte, bitte, bitte.
Deswegen bin ich...
Ja, okay. Ich fähre ich der Häsi.
Ja, natürlich.
Aber ich habe eine Allergie gegen Aspirin,
das wollte ich Ihnen sagen.
Ja, okay. Super. Danke.
Ich weiß nicht, was Sie jetzt geben wollen,
aber ich habe zu Hause über Profen genommen,
das kann ich nicht geholfen.
Ich habe dann Paracetamol genommen,
das hat auch nicht geholfen.
Okay.
Deswegen bin ich jetzt hier.
Ja, okay.
Wie reagieren Sie sich,
die...
Also, Aspirin-Allergie?
Ja, ich bekomme Ausschläge am ganzen Körper,
ich bekomme schlecht Luft.
Und ich bekomme Magenschmerzen.
Okay.
Und hatten Sie früher ähnliche Beschwerden?
Nein, das ist das erste Mal.
Das hatte ich...
Sowas hatte ich noch nie.
Okay.
Und die Fragen, Sie haben mir gesagt,
Sie haben ein Ibuprofen-Tablet
und auch Paracetamol-Tablete eingenommen.
Ja.
Und welche Dosiat-Ubuprofen-Tablete
und wann haben Sie das eingenommen?
Die Ibuprofen, das sind ungefähr zwei Stunden her.
Das war die 600 mg.
600 mg, okay.
Genau.
Und mit dem Mol ist, glaube ich, 500 mg, meine ich.
500 mg, okay.
Und wann haben Sie...
Also Paracetamol jetzt für eine Stunde.
Eine Stunde.
Und Ibuprofen?
Vor zwei Stunden.
Vor zwei Stunden, ja, danke schon.
Und hatten die Tablete dann Ihnen geholfen?
Nein, deswegen bin ich überhaupt nicht angestu...
Ich wusste jetzt nicht mehr, was Sie machen sollen.
Deswegen bin ich hier.
Ja, okay, das ist eine gute Entscheidung.
Würde ich sagen.
Und Herr Kurt, ist Ihnen übel?
So eine ganz leichte Übelkeit habe ich jetzt, ja, das stimmt.
Okay, haben Sie schon einmal erbrochen?
Nein.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, habe ich jetzt auch nicht gemessen, aber ich fühle mich jetzt auch nicht warm im Moment.
Ja, okay.
Heißgefühl, also.
Bitte?
Ein bisschen heiß gefühlt, haben Sie?
Nein, nein, nein, habe ich nicht.
Keine, keine, okay.
Und haben Sie Probleme mit Sturrgang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Wie gesagt, ich habe immer das Gefühl, dass ich auf Toilette muss zum Wasser lassen.
Wie oft?
Seit drei, vier Stunden.
Aber wenn ich auf Toilette gehe, dann kommt kein Urin.
Okay, haben Sie eine Veränderung Ihres Urin bemerkt?
Also konsistent oder Blut von Urin?
Nein, ist mir nicht aufgefallen, nein.
Keine Veränderung.
Okay, und haben Sie Probleme mit Sturrgang?
Nein.
Keine Probleme.
Das war bisher nur.
Ja, okay.
Also wie ist Ihr Schlaf oder Appetit?
Also bisher hatte ich keine Probleme, ist alles gut.
Ja, okay, super.
Appetit?
Ja, okay.
Und haben Sie in letzter Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, an sich nicht, das ist mit dem Gewicht stabil.
Bühlen Sie sich müde?
Müde?
Müde, ja.
Nein.
Okay, Herr Kurt, leiden Sie an irgendwelche Krönchenerkrankungen?
Ich meine Bluthochdruck oder Blutzucker?
Nein, ich habe keine Blutdruck.
Mein Haus hat letztes Jahr einen hohen Blutdruck bei mir festgestellt
und hat mir auch Tabletten verschrieben.
Aber ansonsten Diabetes oder Zucker habe ich jetzt nicht.
Sonst nehme ich auch keine Medikamente ein.
Ja, okay.
Und haben Sie noch etwas Korrektrenke?
Ja, also Ausseht-Bluthochdruck?
Ja, war ich eigentlich relativ gesund.
Ja, okay, super.
Und wie viele Milligramme?
Oh je, Sie fragen Sachen.
Also ich nehme jeden.
Ja, am Morgen, glaube ich, das waren 10 Milligramm, glaube ich.
Ja, 10 Milligramm am Morgen.
Ja, okay.
Noch etwas?
Nein, nur dieses eine.
Ja, okay, so fun.
Und würden Sie schon einmal stationär behandelt oder operär?
Ja, ich glaube, ich habe es schon einmal.
Ich habe es als Studenten, einen kleinen Sportunfall,
da muss ich am Knie operiert werden, aber das war eigentlich alles okay.
Ja.
Da habe ich keine Operationen.
Ja, okay.
Wie alt war sie?
Mit der Knie, okay.
Ja, genau.
Da war ich glaube 23 Jahre alt.
Und noch etwas?
Nein.
Ja, okay.
Okay, haben Sie allergie gehaushalt?
Ja, ich stelle jetzt aber viele Fragen, also die Schmerzen,
nicht besser.
Das, was Sie mir jetzt gegeben haben,
hat jetzt angeschlagen.
Ja.
Also, Herr Kurz,
ja, also um eine Gabe,
Herr Kurz, um eine genaue Diagnose zu stellen, ich muss viele Fragen stellen.
Wissen Sie?
Ja, ich möchte nicht.
Aber die Schmerzen sind ganz schlimm, können Sie nicht erst die Schmerzen ein bisschen...
Ja, ich mache schnell.
Ich mache schnell, ja?
Oh, bitte, bitte, das wird immer noch...
Ja, ich verstehe Sie.
Und bitte beruhigen Sie sich.
Okay?
Ich bin gleich beruhigen, ich wünsche Ihnen diese Schmerzen aber nicht, Frau Doktor.
Ja, ja.
Ich bin immer schlimmer, diese Kohlekind.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Und haben Sie allergen gegen etwas, also außer Assetilizer Liktore?
Nein, nicht bekannt.
Keiner.
Okay.
Und wurden Sie gegen Corona oder Kindererkrankungen geben?
Also meine Impfungen sind komplett.
Ja, super.
Hab ich auch, ja?
Okay, super.
Und Herr Kurt, rauen Sie, wenn ja, was rauen Sie?
Nein, ich rach noch nicht.
Ja, super.
Und trinken Sie gern Alkohol?
Hm, eigentlich sehr, sehr selten, eigentlich nicht.
Selten.
Okay, was meinen Sie selten?
Ja, vielleicht auf dem Geburtstag oder so, aber ansonsten gar nicht.
Okay.
Und Herr Kurt, ich muss eine andere genähte Frage stellen, aber bitte nehmen Sie nicht persönlich.
Haben Sie schon einmal Drogen probiert oder konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Drogen, ich glaube meine Schmerzen sind Süßigkeiten am Abend.
Oh.
Sonst andere Drogen, brauche ich nichts, danke.
Ja, ja, okay, super, aber Süßigkeiten.
Also ist sehr lecker.
Und treiben Sie Sport?
Ja, ich gehe zweimal die Woche ins Fitnessstudio wegen meinen Rücken.
Okay.
Nach der Rückengymnastik und ich versuche regelmäßig mit dem Fahrrad zu fahren, ja.
Fahrradfahren.
Wie oft pro Woche?
Also ich fahre mit dem Fahrrad zu Arbeit, also jeden Tag.
Jeden Tag.
Mhm.
Okay, super.
Und Herr Kurt, wie ist Ihr Familienstadt? Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Ja, super, haben Sie Kinder?
Wir haben drei Kinder, ja.
Drei Kinder, okay, und sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Ja, glückweise, denen geht es gut.
Ja, okay, super.
Und leben Sie mit Ihrer Frau, Rikki?
Ja, ich wohne mit meiner Frau zusammen, genau.
Okay, was machen Sie von mir?
Ich bin Maurer.
Maurer?
Maurer, ich arbeite auf der Baustelle.
Ja, okay, warte.
Ich baue die Mauern von den Häusern.
Ja, okay.
Hatten Ihre Eltern irgendwelche kronische Erkrankungen?
Also leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, meine Eltern leben noch, genau.
Ja, super, super, als ich denke.
Ja, also meine Mutter hat auch einen hohen Blutdruck.
Und auch so leicht durch Blutungsstörungen sind bei ihr bekannt, am Fuß.
Und mein Vater hat auch einen hohen Blutdruck.
Und der hat schon mal einen Herzinfarkt gehabt, jetzt vor fünf Jahren.
Herzinfarkt.
Und Sie haben mir gesagt, also Ihre Mutter hat durch Blutungsstörungen.
Ja, wichtig, aber auf welcher Seite habt ihr es verstanden?
Am rechten Bein.
Am rechten Bein, okay.
Okay, und wie alt war Ihr Vater?
Er lebt ja noch.
Er ist 83 Jahre alt.
83.
Ja, super.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe eine Schwester noch.
Eine Schwester.
Okay, und ist Ihre Schwester gesund?
Ja, nicht ganz.
Also, leider letztes Jahr ein Brustkrebs.
Nein, Sie ist nicht verstorben, Sie lebt.
Ja, ich schuldige, ich habe eine gute Bezirkung.
Und da hat sie eine Therapie bekommen und jetzt geht es ja schon viel besser.
Ja, ja, ich hoffe, das geht immer besser.
Chemotherapie.
Er hat eine Operation, Chemotherapie.
Operation.
Ich weiß nicht genau.
Okay, und wie alt ist Sie?
Sie ist zwei Jahre älter als ich.
Zwei Jahre älter.
Und Herr Kurz, wir sind am Ende des unserem Geschübte.
Ja, wenn ich Sie richtig verstanden habe, Sie haben seit drei Stunden heftige,
also, kollegartige, bellenartige,
erstmalige, linken Unterbauschmerzen.
Ja.
Ja, ich glaube, das passt.
Und Sie haben immer Proben, Tablette und Parasitenmolte, Tablette eingeräumt,
aber die Tabletten, ihnen nicht ganz geholfen.
Und möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Bitte geben Sie mir etwas, dass die Schmerzen besser werden.
Also, das schlägt nicht an dieses, was Sie mir jetzt gegeben haben.
Bitte geben Sie mir eine Infusion, also, die Tablette, die hilft jetzt gar nichts.
Das war die Tablette, die Sie mir jetzt gegeben haben.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie.
Also, Herr Kurz, ich würde als erster Massnahme, würde ich sie körperlich untersuchen
und dann ihnen ein bisschen Blut abnehmen.
Und also, Ultraschall veranlasst, als gegebenenfalls City abdomen,
also City, Bau City durchführen.
Was ist ein City?
Ja, Tomografie, wissen Sie Tomografie?
Computer Tomografie.
Ja, Computer Tomografie.
Ja, genau.
Für die Arschinitöste in Deutschland.
Gehen Sie mir mal vor, ja, was ging die Schmerzen, bitte?
Ja, also, ich muss sie, ich muss sie erst mal körperlich untersuchen.
Ich bitte Sie, Frau Doktor, die Schmerzen werden schlimmer.
Also, das war ja gar nichts, was Sie mir vorhin gegeben haben.
Das hat ja überhaupt gar nichts gebracht.
Geben Sie mir bitte eine Infusion oder eine Spritze, bitte.
Die Schmerzen werden nicht besser.
Ja, ja, okay.
Na, körperlich untersuchen, das kann sein.
Kein Problem.
Okay.
Ich möchte jetzt bitte eine Schmerzmedikation haben.
Das ist schlimm, ich halte es kaum aus.
Das tut jetzt wieder noch, da kommen jetzt wieder die Kodiken.
Ach, Herr Doktor.
Jetzt wird es wieder ganz schlimm.
Ja, okay.
Wollen Sie etwas gegen die Schmerzen geben oder wollen Sie keine geben?
Dann gehe ich woanders hin.
Also, wie ich gesagt habe, ich würde gerne ein Schmerzmutter geben.
Bitte, da ist doch die körperliche Untersuchung.
Können Sie doch nachher machen.
Ja, ich würde gerne eine Schmerzmutter geben.
Bitte, da ist doch die körperliche Untersuchung.
Können Sie doch nachher machen.
Ja, okay.
Wenn Sie das möchten oder wenn Sie das so halten, diese Schmerzen.
Bitte Sie.
Ansonsten rufen Sie bitte Ihren Oberarzt.
Ja, Herr Kurt, also ich habe große Erfahrung.
Und natürlich, ich werde mit meinem Oberarzt über Ihre Fall besprechen.
Ja, Sie sind gut geworden und bitte beruhigen Sie sich.
Ja, aber die Schmerzen.
Keine Sorge.
Ich mache mir schon Sorgen.
Ja.
Ich möchte jetzt gerne eine Infusion haben, damit die Schmerzen endlich hier nachlassen.
Körperliche Untersuchungen oder was Sie auch machen möchten,
können Sie von mir aus alles später machen.
Aber ich brauche jetzt etwas gegen die Schmerzen, bitte.
Ja, okay.
Verstehe.
Danke.
Ich habe einen Kollegen oder Kolleginnen und andere Fragen.
Ja, Doktor, ich frage Sie, warum Sie das nicht tun?
Ja, Herr Kurt, aber Sie sagen, Sie haben einen Schmerz.
Oder Sie haben einen Schmerz.
Ich frage noch einen Kollegen.
Können Sie sich hier was erlassen, Generalbeschreiben?
Ich habe einen Handrank, wenn ich auf die Toilette gehe, kommt nur ganz wenig.
Und dann ist vorbei.
Okay.
Ganz langsam.
Wenn ein Leid ist, ist dabei beim Wasserlassen.
Noch nicht.
Wenn ein Schmerz beim Wasserlassen...
Brennen nicht, aber ein bisschen ziehen nach dem Wasserlassen.
Wie gesagt, die Schmerzen haben erst vor drei Stunden angefangen.
Am Anfang haben sie die Schmerzen auf der linken Seite und auf der rückenden Seite.
Und danach auf der linken Seite.
Leiste.
Also Leiste.
Genauer gesagt, das strahlt in den linken Hoden.
Hoden.
Okay.
Danke schön.
Das war es.
Das hat die Frau Doktor aber nicht gefragt.
Ne, sie ist nicht gefragt.
Hoden ist nicht gefragt.
Wir haben eine Gefracht, die für den Ausstrahlung ist.
Aber Leiste.
Ich habe das Leiste gesagt.
Ja, Leiste.
Können wir als Ersatzgeschichte anfangen?
Okay.
Bitte schön.
Ja, okay.
Super.
Keine
Aufnahme.
Das ist ein 54-Jähriger Patient, der sich heute Morgen bei uns in der
Nataufnahme wegen seit drei Stunden aufgetretene, bestehende,
erstmalige, also plötsch aufgetretene.
Ja.
Wellenform, kollegartige, linken Unterbauchschmerzen mit Ausstrahlung in
der Leistenbereich vorgestellt hat.
Und der Patient berichtet, dass die Schmerzen vom linken Flanken an
Unterbauch gewandert seien.
Und der Patient erwandte, dass die Schmerzen, also 9 von
10 auf der Schmerzkala seien und sich im Verlauf
verschlechtert hatten.
Und der Patient habe ein Ibuprofen-Tablette und ein Paracetamol-Tablette
dagegen, also gegen diese Schmerzen eingenommen.
Aber die Tabletten bei ihm nicht ganz geholfen.
Okay.
Ja.
Und die Patienten sind die folgenden Begleitsymptome aufgefallen.
Also Noah, Übbelkind würde ich sagen und auch Oligri und
Handrank und Polleküste.
Ja, Sölder.
Algüri oder Dysir.
Und Noah.
Ich möchte mal wissen, wie die Algüri, die Schmerzen,
die Schmerzen sind.
Ich möchte wissen, wie die Algüri, die Schmerzen sind.
Die Oligüri oder die Polleküste.
Die Oligüri, die Polleküste.
Die Imperativ und Handrank.
Ja, okay.
Im Kontinens oder?
Im Kontinens ist es nicht.
Nein.
Nein, im Kontinens ist es nicht.
Und die Vegetativ-Anamnesis ist unauffällig.
Bis auf, ja, ich glaube, kein Gut.
Und der Patient hat gesagt und er hat kein Fieber.
Und die Fragen, die Fragen nach Müdigkeit, also Erbrochen,
Erbrechen oder Schlafstörungen in Appätenz, wurden von dem
Patient verneint.
Und noch etwas, ich glaube, das war es.
An Vorerkrankungen, leider ja, Arterialhypertonie, seit
einem Jahr ein.
Und Medikamente.
Und er nimmt am Lodipin 10 mg am Abend ein.
Morgens.
Morgens, ja, genau.
Am Morgens.
Ja, ich habe morgens geschüttet, aber abends gesagt.
Ja, entschuldigung.
Ja, und als Operationen, er ist mit 23 Jahre wegen Knie
operiert worden.
Und allergen, er hat Assetilizulixur, also Aspirin-Allergie.
Und die sich atmenut und also Hautausschlag aussagt.
Und ja, Impfstatus ist komplett und ist nicht roh.
Und nicht roh.
Und er trinkt gelegantisch Alkohol, Drogen, Konsum,
Verneid, Ausersüßigkeit.
Ja, und Sport, also so den sportlichen Aktivitäten gehört,
Fitnessstudien, und jeden Tag Fahrradfahren,
zum Arbeitgehen.
Und als Sozialanamnese, er ist verheiratet und hat drei
Kinder, lebt oder wohnt mit seiner Frau zusammen,
er ist Mauer in Baustelle.
Was ist das bitte?
Was war ein Beruf, übt er aus?
Mauer in Baustelle, richtig?
Mauer, M-A-U-R-E-R, Mauer.
Das wird, das weiß ich nicht, deswegen habe ich nicht.
Danke schön.
Und als Familienanamnese, die Mutter des Patienten hat Arterialhypertone
und Durczblutungsstörung am rechten Bein.
Ja, also, und der Vater des Patienten hat auch Bluthochdruck
und hat Herzinfarkt vor fünf Jahren.
Und er hat eine Schwester und die Schwester des Patienten
hat Brustkrebs, Lungenkrebs, und mit Chemotherapie
und behandelt wurden.
Ja, ich glaube das war es.
Ganz kurz, hat sie jetzt Lungenkrebs und Brustkrebs
oder beides oder nur eins?
Also, hat nicht gefragt, Lungenkrebs, ich glaube.
Wir haben gerade ihm gesagt, er hat Lungenkrebs,
die Schwester hat Lungenkrebs.
Ja, der Patient hat mir gesagt Brustkrebs,
aber ich habe gedacht, das ist ein Lungenkrebs.
Brustkrebs ist Mama Katzinow.
Ja, okay, okay, okay.
Brust ist die Mama, okay?
Ja, okay, okay.
Also, genauer Anamnese bitte Frau Doktor.
Ja, ja.
Wenn Sie Patienten befragen, müssen Sie genau die Anamnese befragen.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht sehen, bitte nochmal nach.
Ja, natürlich.
Okay, was haben Sie denn auf welcher Seite?
Was ist Ihre Verdachtstdiagnose
und was haben Sie den Patienten gegen seine Schmerzen gegeben?
Ja, also, Anamnesterchen angaben durch den Amelisten
auf piole Neppitisin.
Piole Neppitis?
Ja.
Okay.
Ja, und als Differenzier...
Ja, okay, aber weiß nicht.
Okay.
Als Differenzier, die Diatmosen kommen in den Folgen,
in Betra.
Also Divertikulitis.
Okay.
Gastroenteritis.
Und Prostatakarsinum.
Prostatakarsinum?
Ja.
Wie kommen Sie mit Prostatakarsinum, Frau Doktor?
Ja, also...
Okay, wir lassen es verstehen.
Ich glaube, Gewichtverlust.
Der Patient kommt mit Gewichtverlust, aber der Patient...
Stopp, der Patient hat keinen Gewichtsverlust.
Er hat gesagt, er hat keinen Gewichtverlust.
Ja, ich weiß.
Ja, das ist ein Problem.
Keine Vermutungen anstellen.
Sie müssen genau fragen.
Wir können es nachher diskutieren.
Prostatakarsinum, das lassen wir mal stehen,
aber passt eigentlich nicht.
Ja.
Aber was anderes?
Was ist das Klassische?
Jemand mit kolikartigen Schmerz...
Nierenkolik.
Die von der Niere in die Leiste führen.
Was ist das typischerweise?
Und Hörden.
Nephrolitiasis.
Genau, ganz einfach.
Nieresteine.
Wo sind die Steine, wenn sie aus der Niere rauskommen?
Ja.
Im Hanleiter.
Also ein Hanleiterstein, wahrscheinlich.
Das ist eher die Diagnose.
Okay?
Ja.
Gut. Was haben Sie gegen die Schmerzen gegeben?
Ja, also ich würde...
Die ganzen Schmerzen können ja ganz, ganz häflich
und ganz schlimm...
Natürlich.
Ich würde als Erste ein Schmerz mit Zell verordnen.
Welches?
Schmerz mit Zell.
Ja, also...
Nichts, die Reudelle, Anti-Infrematur.
Was gibt man bei den Nieren am meisten gleich als erstes?
Was gut hilft und als Infusion auch ganz gut ist.
Ja.
Der Kolikant. Welche Schmerzmedikamente?
Er hat ja schon Stil.
Er hat ja Ibuprofen und Paracetamol genommen.
Das hat ihm ja nicht gehört.
Metamysol oder?
Genau.
Neuagin.
Wie viel geben Sie?
Also, die Dosis bei mir ist nicht nahrlich,
aber ich würde IV geben.
Sie sind doch eine erfahrene Ärztin mit Notaufnahme.
Ja, genau.
Wie viel gibt man in einem akuten Fall?
500 Milligramm.
Aufradokta.
Ein kleines Kind. 1 Gramm.
1 Gramm Neuagin.
Die Kollegen haben es richtig hingewiesen.
Dann würde ich auch noch Buscopan dazugeben.
Ja, natürlich.
Polikant etwas nachlassen.
Also 1 Gramm, gleich als Infusion, schnell reinlaufen lassen.
Wenn Sie 1 Gramm Neuagin als Infusion schnell geben,
was kann passieren?
Syncopo oder was?
Ich habe einmal 1.
Also, woher kommt die Syncopo, was passiert vorher?
Kreislaufprobleme.
Übelkeit, Kreislauf, Depression.
Du müsst natürlich auch immer fragen, ob eine Allergie ist.
Ja, natürlich.
Aber Kreislauf kann manchmal etwas runtergehen.
Also Buscopan, Neuagin, okay?
Sehr gut.
Ja, natürlich.
Frau Doktor, Frau Doktor, Frau Doktor.
Okay, haben noch Kollegen oder haben Sie noch Fragen, Frau Doktor?
Ja, also als Apparativdiagnose.
Ja, natürlich.
Als Apparativdiagnose würde ich Sonografie des Abtomans.
Was wollen Sie im Ultraschall sehen?
Nierenstein.
Was noch?
Das kann sein.
Und bei Verdacht auf Nierenstein ist, kann man sagen.
Ja, aber was wollen Sie im Ultraschall sehen mit der Nieren?
Wenn ein Nierenstein da ist,
dann kann man das manchmal sein.
Also ich würde sagen, das heißt ein Stau.
Sie möchten einen Nierenstau ausschließen.
Genau.
Das ist das Wichtigste.
Ob da ein Nierenstau da ist.
Ja, genau.
Und der Patient sagt mir, also er klagt über Oligurie.
Deswegen, das ist sehr wichtig.
Genau, das heißt, Sie wollen auch dann noch Urin kontrollieren?
Ja, natürlich.
Urinkultur und auch Urinstatus natürlich.
Im Urinstatus können wir hohe Nitrat, hohe Nitritz sehen
oder manchmal Blutkörpschen sehen.
Herr Mogulabin.
Was kann man noch machen, wenn Sie haben es vorhin bei der Anamnese schon gesagt?
Die Computer-Tomographie.
Ja, natürlich.
Dass man sieht, gegebenenfalls wo dieser Stein liegt.
Natürlich.
Was machen Sie mit dem?
Sie haben jetzt Ultraschall gemacht.
Der hat einen Nierenaufstau, 1. Gradis.
Und 1. 2.
Der hat Schmerzen, kann schlecht Wasser lassen.
Ja, okay.
Computer-Tomographie.
Das gibt, vielleicht sollten Sie das als Hausaufgaben machen,
3 Engstellen an einem Hahnleiter, wo die Steine hängen bleiben können.
Also ich habe so gedacht, als erstes würde ich die große des Steins beurteilen.
Das ist richtig.
Ein Zentimeter würde ich eine Orallösung haben.
Nierensteine sind 1 cm groß, die sind immer nur wenige Millimeter groß.
Ja, Millimeter, ja, natürlich.
Ich habe gefragt, es gibt 3 natürliche Engstellen vom Hahnleiter.
3 natürliche Engstellen.
Aufschreiben, nachlesen, gucken, wo ist das?
Wo ist das?
Ich habe eine Permittung, permittiv.
Wo können diese Steine im Hahnleiter hängen bleiben?
Die Mündung konnte die...
Sind Sie Oralogen?
Nein, nein, ich bin hier frei.
Ach so, nicht helfen, nicht aushelfen, stopp.
Ja, ich weiß nicht genau, aber ich habe eine Permittung
und zwischen dem Hahnleiter und zwischen dem Hahnbläser.
Ja, genau, das ist...
Also, Nierenbecken, der Bereich zwischen Nierenbecken und Hahnblase
ist der Hahnleiter.
Ja.
Und es gibt 3 Stellen an dem Hahnleiter, wo diese Steine hängen bleiben können.
Das lesen Sie bitte nach, okay?
Ja, okay, natürlich.
Ich habe vorlesen.
Das kann eine Prüfungsfrage sein.
Ja, okay.
Was macht man denn?
Jetzt haben Sie Computertomographie gemacht
und sehen, dass der Stein in der Einmündung zu Hahnblase feststeckt.
Nefrectome.
Es geht von alleine nicht weg.
Nefrectome, nefrostome.
Was?
Nefrostome, nefrostome, das ist nicht richtig.
Nefrectome?
Nefrostome.
Doktor, dann nervt dich.
Oh je, zu Ihnen komme ich nicht mehr, Frau Doktor.
Ja, ich...
Sie sind zu radikal.
Nefrectome, oder...
Momentan, wir...
Ne liberties.